[Music]
drex here from drexfactorpoi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
recently i started up a new live
streaming course that i'm really excited
about we had our first session last week
and our second session is going to be
tonight that is tuesday august
16th as i'm sitting here
um this lesson went so well that i kind
of wanted to share it with a lot of you
all out there and give you a taste of
what this course is looking like but
before we dive into that uh quick shout
out to the friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les muchinski and
becca beckham thank you all so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission
hey so a few weeks ago i posted about
the fact that i think that we kind of
teach poi wrong right now and i launched
an online course to try and teach poi
the way i think it ought to be taught or
at least the way that i wish that i had
been taught and the first class turned
out really really well so to give you
all an idea of the vibe that i'm looking
for with this i wanted to post an edited
version of the first lesson that covers
plane facing as well as
poi reels now the original lesson was an
hour long and it included a lot of basic
information about poi as well as the
whole theory behind the class i've cut
all of that out so i can just focus on
the lesson for you all
so it's like roughly 20 minutes long now
but
it should give you a rough idea of what
it's like being in these live livestream
lessons and
hopefully that is something that you'll
enjoy i'll be back again after the
lesson to tell you how you can sign up
for these live stream classes and get to
be a part of all this so let's go check
it out welcome and thank you all so much
for signing up to take this class with
me
um
i
just want to do a quick intro
what up i'm drex um i've been teaching
poi now for probably 13-ish years
and i came to a point where
i wanted to teach people poi the way
that i wish
that i had been
taught poi
so
we're going to be doing a physical
warm-up and then we're going to have a
lesson that is going to cover some poi
tricks how to use them some of the
theory behind them as well as um how you
can apply them with some of those body
movements we're going to do a quick
warm-up
here's what i want you to do
go ahead and either like wrap up your
poi in your hands or set the poi down
make sure that
my outline stays there and what i want
you to do is go ahead and start
pull your stuff down make sure you
you've got yourself a little bit of room
here and everything and start rolling
your wrists turn your wrists eight times
outwards so that's one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight now turn them inwards eight
six
five
four
three
two
one roll your shoulders back
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one roll them forwards eight
seven
six
five four
three
two
one roll your elbows back
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two one times roll them forwards eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
reach your right hand to the sky
reach your left hand to the sky
raise your left hand to the sky oh quick
note here when you're reaching your hand
up don't shrug don't pull your shoulder
to your ear keep your shoulder down
you're only reaching as far as you can
without raising your shoulder up um this
is both because it is better for your
shoulder as well as it creates a more
pleasing line when when you're moving it
around anyway right hand up
left hand up
really reach for the sky there right
hand up
left hand up
right hand up
left hand up one more time
left hand up beautiful
now i want you to try exploring the
space around you with the tippy top of
your head see how far you can reach your
head in every direction
you're going to look like you are
tripping real hard on something and you
know what it's okay we're all doing it
out here cool now we're gonna do the
same thing with our fingertips again
explore the space around you
reach as far as you can to either side
keep your feet riveted in place but
really really stretch around explore how
high you can reach
explore how low you can reach next up
we're going to explore the space
with our hips explore space with our
hips reach out to the sides
reach back and forward
get low
get high
just try and fill up
the space around you with those hips
we're going to start off today
by learning something that like
basically you don't
it is almost impossible to get into poi
without having to
uh grapple with this particular concept
whenever you spin the poi there will
always be a side that looks like it's
clockwise and a side looks like it's
counterclockwise when it appears to be
one or the other it means that you're on
a specific side of it we call this plane
facing so if i'm standing
on this side of it it looks to me like
counterclockwise
if i'm standing on this side of it it
looks like it's clockwise yeah we're
going to learn how to do that using a
move called a reel i want you to pick
two walls in whatever room you happen to
be in
that's going to be my forward wall
that's going to be my reverse wall
why are we doing this well it's because
we're going to
switch between facing each of these
walls
we're going to be turning with the poi
in such a way that we're actually going
to be changing how uh we are oriented
with the plane facing of the poi i want
you to just get the poi spinning at your
sides like you're you're going to treat
them like a jump rope yeah
and i want you to just spin them
forwards here
you got one on either side of the body
it's like you're kind of boxed in
between two wheels of a wagon yeah and i
want you to just practice spinning the
poi for 10 reps yeah now i want you to
spin the poi
reverse that is they're coming back at
you so on the bottom they appear to be
moving away and on the top they're
coming back up behind your shoulders
yeah and again let's get in 10 beats
like this cool
now
wrap the poi up in your hands what i
want you to do is face the forwards wall
and kind of pantomime the poi moving
forwards for me yeah
we're going to turn from the forward
side to the reverse side how do we do
that well when you are pushing the when
you're pushing your hands and poi out
away from you freeze with them at their
furthest point and what i want you to do
is i want you to sweep both of your
hands
down past your your knees
and then bring them back around facing
the reverse wall and now you're going to
pantomime moving them in reverse it's
almost like you're you're giving
somebody a come hither motion yeah
cool
so
facing the forward wall we're going to
go we're going to pan some i'm going
forward pushing it away once twice three
times four times five times sweep them
past your legs and then come hither five
four
three
two one times uh there's something going
on here that i really want you to pay
attention to and that is when we go from
like pushing away
to
come hither did you see how
the poi started my hands and poi started
on each side of my body like boxing me
in like those wagon wheels and then i
switched them both over to the same side
of my body as they're sweeping past my
hips and knees
and then
when i complete my turn here
they each go to
each side of my body again so it's two
tracks
one track
two tracks is what's happening and like
don't overthink this all you really have
to do is like keep your arms square to
your body and just like turn your upper
body from side to side in fact
try doing that right now
try reaching your arms away from
yourself and
you know it's really just this motion
right here you're letting your arms drop
and then come away drop and come away
drop and come away and when they drop
boom
you just turn to face the opposite wall
boom turn to face the opposite wall
so
drop sweep and come up drop sweep and
come up let's try that with the poi now
so again we can sweep
down past
down past down past down past yeah
just try doing that sweep with me for a
second going down past our ankles down
past down past down past and all you're
doing is you're keeping your arms square
with your body as you're turning your
upper body from side to side here yeah
from the side let me show you it just
looks like this
we're more or less keeping both of the
poi on the same side of the body as
we're doing this yeah we're going to
start with our poi spinning forwards
make sure you're facing your forwards
wall
and as the poi are spinning here
i want you to drop them both down past
now as they come to the other side of
your body here
what you're going to be anticipating is
for them to switch into reverse that is
they're going to come up back at you
there can sometimes be like a little bit
of a sketchy moment there when we see
the poi coming at us like oh no oh no
um
know that it's coming in anticipated
right because again our brains really
really want for this to be forward and
for this to be forward as well but
that's not the way the poi want to move
start on the forward side give me five
four
three
two
one beats and then sweep down and round
five four three
two
one beats going reverse now you'll note
that as i'm doing that sweep i'm still
letting my arms do that thing where
they're sweeping down with the poi and
that is 100 deliberate i want you to use
your full arms for this too not only
will it help keep the poi from getting
tangled around your body but also it'll
start to reinforce information that the
poi should be thought of as being
extensions of your arms which is very
very core to my theory of poi dance yeah
from the side what this looks like
five four three
two
one sweep them down and around five four
three
two
one yeah this inevitably does bring up
the question though of how do we get
from the reverse side to the forward
side i'm so glad that you asked
wrap up the poi in your hands again
let's walk through this together so
we're going to face our reverse wall
and again i want you to pantomime
that you're you're doing that come
hither motion you're doing that come
hither motion right
and as you're doing that come hither
motion at that moment when your hands
are furthest away from you
what i want you to do is
reach up towards the sky
turn your body
and then let them drop down on the other
side yeah
let's look at that again
as you're doing come hither when they're
out away from you
reach up and around your hands are going
to go up past your eyeballs
come down on the other side
into that
go away motion yeah again it's really
really really important to make sure
that your hands are always in view like
you don't want one hand to kind of go
behind your head or what have you there
should never be a point at which you you
are not able to see both of your hands
at the same time yeah um for this one
just as we played around with the idea
of like dropping our arms and coming
back up this one's going to be raising
our arms and coming back down raising
our arms and coming back down try and do
just this for a second we're starting
with our arms straight out raise them up
bring them down raise them up bring them
down and when i say bring them down
they're coming to shoulder height no
lower raise them up bring them down
raise them up bring them down
face your reverse side
bring them up
turn your upper body to the forward side
bring them down
again
raise them up return to the reverse side
bring them down
raise them up turn to the forward side
try and sweep up and over back and forth
like you're taking an object off of your
counter and putting it over on the
kitchen table you're just being really
extra about it right so let's try this
with the poi shall we
so i want you to spin the poi reverse on
your reverse side going five four
three
two
one sweep them over and let them drop
into forwards on the other side
make sure that you can always see your
hands and poi as they go up and over in
fact i would highly recommend rather
than like reaching for the ceiling as
you're doing this instead maybe kind of
reach away from you do you see how i'm
like kind of pushing them away as much
as i'm bringing them up
and that way i can keep my eyes on both
of the poi and hands at all time
and guess what when you do it this way
your audience really can't tell the
difference
you just push them away and bring them
back down it's almost like you're kind
of like um throwing a boomerang and
having it come back at you yeah let's
drill this in five four three
two
one push them away and back down
five four three two one outstanding
let's do that again
on the reverse side
we go five four three
two
one push the mountain away and let him
come back down five four three
two one
really really really important make sure
that you initiate that turn when the poi
are pointed away from you don't do it
when they're coming back down towards
your shoulders because unpleasant things
are going to happen make sure it's
always when you're pushing them away
from you that you're continuing that
motion so i'm going to give you the last
piece of this here which is just we're
gonna go back and forth between the two
yeah so i want you to start off facing
your forward side and get your poi
spinning forwards by your sides
we're gonna
turn to reverse going five four three
two
one sweep them down and around to
reverse five four three two
one take it back to forwards again we go
five four
three
two one sweep them down in your rounds
five four three two
one bringing up and over going back and
forth between the two yeah so here's the
thing i want you all to do with this
i want you all
to start doing things like boom finding
poses as
you're going around to all these
positions here
move with the poi
try out some level changes
see what happens if you take a couple
steps as
you make these turns happen
see what happens if you wind up down low
with them
see what happens
if you wind up up high with them
there is literally no reason that you
can't get a little extra with this stuff
in fact i want you to
please
get extra with your real turns here
there's no reason that we can't make
these dancy just the way they are so
cool there you have it i hope you
enjoyed this a little taster of the ways
that i am teaching uh this here course
if you'd like to sign up for the rest of
the session you can do so over at
crowdcast dot io slash drexfactorpoi
this is unit one of my poi dancing
course
i'll include a link to that down in the
description and i think i can also
include a link to it up in the cards if
you are watching this video on youtube
and also just so you know if you happen
to live in a time zone where it is not
convenient to watch the live streams
every single one of these classes is
recorded so you can go back and review
it any old time you want and i will be
rechecking the chat to answer questions
if they happen to pop up after the fact
[Music]
cool so if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video as well as to help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible were not for the kind support
of all of these nice people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on my
channel possible thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter and would
like to become one you can do so by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
um that will get you a whole access to a
whole bunch of awesome rewards as well
as helping me out in my mission of
bringing poi spinning and flow arts to
the broader world and helping people
connect with their brains and their
bodies as creative individuals so go
check that out please and thank you and
hey the course that i'm teaching is
actually a new version of a course that
i taught a couple years ago
during the beginning of the covet 19
quarantine i will go ahead and leave a
link to playlist of those videos down in
the description
as well as up on screen if you are
watching on youtube the youtube
algorithm also thinks that you'll really
like this top video right here so you
might want to check that out as well
thank you all so much for watching uh
please make sure to get out the flow
today and i'll see you with a new video
on thursday
peace